moments ago
together with president of iran mr
rouhani and president of
turkey mr erdogan have concluded
my very interesting talks on syria
the talks have been constructive and
very business-like
i'd like to note that our meeting in
this trilateral format
are now very regular this is the fourth
meeting so far such
coordination allows us to effectively
work towards long-term normalization
in the syrian arab republic together
with our partners we have defined the
key areas for further cooperation for
the sake of
settling the syrian crisis the
agreements we've reached
can be found in our joint statement
it is very important that both three
guarantees states all
three guaranteed states are willing and
ready to
improve cooperation within the astana
process
which has proven to be effective we will
continue to
expand our efforts in our fight against
terrorism we will continue
our negotiated political process in
syria
we will continue our practice of regular
meetings on the expert level with the
participation of delegations from
guaranteed states
from syria from syrian parties uh from
the government and the opposition in
syria
and the un officials of course we have
agreed that the 12th round of
consultations
will take place in astana in late march
early april
the astana 3 continues contacts
extensive contacts with all the
interested parties and international
organizations
some countries have said
that they would like to also participate
in the astana
process as observers and we have
been working to allow them to
receive this status i'd like to
underline that
thanks to russia iran and turkey a
positive environment has been created to
resolve the crisis we are convinced that
we can only achieve
uh positive results in syria through
negotiated political process
according to 2254 resolution of the u.n
security council
and uh only if we respect the principles
of sovereignty
unity and territorial integrity of syria
we believe that it is the syrians
themselves that have to define
the future of their country there is no
other way to move forward
so we looked at the issues
of promoting and furthering the domestic
syrian political process we have agreed
to
launch the constitutional committee as
soon as possible which will
tackle the basic aspects of the future
government of the syrian arab republic
the candidates are still
are mostly agreed upon by the syrian
government and the opposition
now we need to agree on the final list
on the participates
the participants of the committee and to
decide on the basic
functions of the committee
we believe that this success will
allow damascus to normalize relations
with arab states
to restore its connections with the arab
league
and improve stability and security
in the region on the whole during our
talks the members the three guarantee
states
uh agreed that we both we are
all uh we will all fight against
terrorism
and enhance stability in the region
we have discussed the idlib escalation
zone as well i would like to say that
our
iranian and turkish allies
would like to work with us to remove all
escalation in idlib and
improve the situation there we have
agreed a number of steps to promote the
situation to improve the situation
uh ceasefire should not impede our
anti-terrorist efforts though and i'd
like to say that the creation of the
idlib de-escalation zone is a temporary
measure
aggressive operations of the militants
should not be left unpunished during our
talks we've also
discuss the ways
how the american plans to withdraw their
troops from
syria will influence the situation
we believe that the implementation of
these steps would be
a positive development it would help
stabilize the situation
in in a part of syria
where control by the legitimate
government need to be restored
we have discussed at length uh the
humanitarian efforts
towards the syrian people we have
discussed the help towards the refugees
uh the astana three are doing
a lot in this area without support the
syrian arab republic has created
conditions for uh
over one and a half million people to
be helped the refugees to be helped and
there will be non-discriminatory
approach towards anyone who wants to
return to their homeland
in order to radically improve the
situation in syria to restore the
economy
restore the society this would require
collective efforts from
all of the international community we
call on the
international community and
international organizations and
firstly the un of course to help syrians
to
return to normal life to peaceful life
to overcome the
conflict in conclusion i'd like to thank
my
iranian and turkish counterparts mr
rouhani mr erdogan
for this productive and very
constructive talks we've had today
i'm sure that the results of the summit
will help promote
more productive work towards the peace
and stability in the syrian arab
republic
thank you
in the name of the lord the almighty and
the merciful
i would like to thank his excellency the
russian president
mr putin for
hosting this important
meeting in the beautiful city of sochi
and also i would like
to thank
him for his hospitality on behalf of the
people of um
syria and the syrian government this is
our fourth summit within the astana
format
our common objective is
to combat terrorism
resolutely and restore stability and
security
in syria to help syrians
develop a new constitution strengthen
democracy in syria and
enable refugees to go back to their
homes as well as post-war
reconstruction in syria during today's
meeting which was
highly helpful and
candid and open-minded
we discussed the necessity to continue
our fight against
terrorism in the remaining hotbeds
in syria including the region of idlib
we all agreed that
decreasing tension in the presence of
warner states on a temporary basis in
syria
are necessary idlib is part of syria
and it must be cleansed of
terrorists a terrorist must leave this
country
they are intruders there there are many
things
that are alarming
many of those terrorists are currently
in prisons
and if they go back to their home
countries uh
they may engage in terrorist activities
in their countries and regions
we've already been witnessing that and
we are concerned that
some of the members of isis may get
transferred from syria to afghanistan
and that might be very dangerous for
the entire middle east and central asia
as well as the rest of the world we
must not
enable terrorists to get support under a
veneer
of a fight against terrorism and
the united states uh heaven has
announced
that they were going to withdraw their
troops from syria
but according to our information they
intend to continue to interfere in the
domestic
affairs of syria regardless of how many
american boots
remain on the ground in syria it must be
up to
syrians to decide their own future and
that's
important
it is important that the americans
realize that kurds are also
part a part of syria and syria is
one people and it must enjoy territorial
integrity
this principle of territorial integrity
for syria
was emphasized during today's meeting
even though we do realize that security
of syria's
neighboring countries must also be
insured
including the security of turkey turkey
must
feel safe on its
border with syria we would like to
we would like all neighboring countries
around syria to have
friendly good neighbor relations with
this country
and in order to
ensure long-term security for syria
that is why we must uh both respect
syria's territorial integrity
and pay attention to the rights of
syria's kurds and also
focus on neutralizing and destroying
terrorist groups
so all these aspects received
attention a great deal of attention from
us
during today's meeting
also the illegal unlawful and
illegitimate
interference by the zionist
regime in syria uh also
is a matter of concern for syria and for
for syrians
and for other countries of the region
israelis
violate syria's airspace from uh
through lebanon uh they bombed syrian
territory at will
unfortunately the united nations and
responsible
parties in the world keep silent uh
with regard to such incidents to such
occurrences and this silence means that
they do not want
uh safety and security
in total for syria and for the entire
region
we are happy that the three warranter
nations
are investing their efforts to
decrease tension in syria and ensure
long-term stability in this country
from the very start we believed that
uh it
should be a political uh objective
to resolve the situation in syria that
it doesn't have a military solution
and we've been hoping that after many
years of suffering
syrians will finally be able to enjoy
peace and security therefore the
international community
must contribute its efforts to enable
syrian refugees to go back
to their homes as soon as possible and
to ensure the reconstruction of syria
and i believe that the cooperation of
our three important nations in this
region
over syria will be very important
for restoring security in syria
maybe nobody would believe
that peace would be restored in syria
a while ago and that damascus would be
able to continue running its own country
uh therefore the cooperation among our
three countries
uh on a global level uh our cooperation
for peace is highly important we also
believe
that the united nations and all the
countries in the world should
assist this process should support this
process and this format might also
prove very efficient for resolving
regional issues and
the the way our three countries are
putting in their effort to ensure
security and peace for syria
we could similarly do that for the
entire region
and uh uh use this cooperation for
any areas that that would require our
attention thank you
my friend mr putin
mr rouhani members of the delegations
members of the media and the press i
welcome
every one of you here
before i begin i'd like to express my
gratitude
for the hospitality of mr putin
using this opportunity i'd like to
express my condolences
to the people of iran
what happened yesterday the terrorist
act that happened yesterday
the best to the people who were wounded
in the act
over many years we have been fighting
against the pkk terrorist organizations
tens of thousands of our people have
died
in the attacks of this organization
no matter what form this terrorist
organization
takes in the end they will be destroyed
eliminated whether it happens in iran
or in turkey all terrorists will be
eliminated
today we have held very productive
successful talks with my counterparts
we have discussed the results of
previous meetings and we have discussed
uh measures for promoting peace in syria
together we have consulted on
potential further steps to
resolve the conflict in the region
on the other hand
the discussed uh the ceasefire we have
discussed idlib and
a number of other issues were also on
our agenda i'd like to
underline that
we believe it's very important to
resolve the situation
in idlib our syrian brothers
have paid a very high price have
suffered a lot over the past years
we wish that neither
syria nor any other region suffers
such a humanitarian crisis ever again
turkey has
done a lot to
overcome all of the differences and
despite all of the provocations
to maintain peace and security in idlib
we
are doing everything to compl to
implement the idlib memorandum
i have given my friend
my friends both uh
my iranian counterpart and russian
counterpart our wishes to how to
implement the inlet memorandum
oh we have discussed also the
the provocation initiatives that we need
to
um overcome
also we have just assessed the
decision by the us to withdraw his
troops from syria
undoubtedly if this happens
trump's decision will have a great
effect
their removal removal of their forces
should not
lead to a vacuum of power and should not
lead to a
domination by the pyd and the people's
protection units
and the ypg we believe
that we need to take into account the
territorial integrity of syria
and we need to eliminate terrorist
organizations and other threats
as part of our process of
conflict resolution the zones that
will be created as a result need to be
transferred
under the authority to the authority of
the syrian government
there's a terrorist corridor on the
southern
uh borders of syria and we
expect our partners and our allies to
establish
a safe zone there as well we have
discussed the altam
peace agreement
we have also discussed everything that
could be done to
achieve a political resolution we have
assessed to the stage
we are at we believe that at this moment
there needs to be a constitutional
committee
and in cooperation with the un uh these
committees should be
come operational three guaranteed states
have done a lot to achieve a
political negotiated political process
when
if we have traversed ac we cannot allow
ourselves to drown in a in a river
so to speak so we have achieved quite a
lot
and those who thrive on chaos and
instability should not succeed
friends in the upcoming
future we should focus on creating
constitutional committee
we have also discussed the problem of uh
refugees returning to their homes over
three million
refugees syrian refugees have found
refuge in our country turkey
has the most refugees of any country in
the world
it in this difficult times we have
helped our brothers
no matter what their ethnic or religious
background we
have given refuge to all of the refugees
that flew from flew away
and escaped from the
regime or from the terrorists
we have also discussed the problem of
the issue of helping the refugees return
to their homes in a peaceful manner
and deliberately
uh during the euphrates euphrates
the euphrates shield operation over 300
000 refugees have returned to their
homes
now they live in more secure regions
it is all thanks to the measures taken
by
our country
i believe that this model can be applied
in manbij and in
the eastern euphrates region as well
to help the refugees we need to prepare
humanitarian infrastructure
and turkey is ready to contribute a lot
to that
but the international community as
a part of a just
joint effort needs to contribute as well
but
we haven't seen that so far
while we see some effort in terms of
helping refugees we don't
hear a lot about the efforts towards
rebuilding syria
uh we believe that our efforts today
will help restore
stability in syria the three guaranteed
states have
been decisive in their stance
that um the
syrian problem the syrian crisis needs
to be resolved according to u.n
resolution 2254
together with mr putin and mr rouhani we
believe that
we need to we have achieved a lot thanks
to this summit
um the next meeting
of our summit will take place in the
upcoming
months and we have agreed
on the on the
time that this new meeting will take
place thank you
now reporters from three countries will
be able
to ask one question each to the three
presidents and let's start from
iranian press corps
in the name of allah the almighty and
the merciful
uh dear president putin dear
president erdogan and their president
rouhani i would like to
greet all of our fellow citizens who are
watching
this broadcast i have a question for
president rouhani
but um the other presidents can also
answer that if they
wish to the future of idlib
including the uh eastern bank of the
euphrates
river how do you see that future and
what was discussed with regard to it
today
opinion of the three guaranteed states
and the opinion of the international
community is that the entirety of the
territory of syria
needs to be under the legitimate under
the control
and the visible control of a legitimate
government
whether it's idlib or the eastern bank
of euphrates
all of syria's territory belongs to the
people of syria territorial integrity
sovereignty of syria have been
emphasized by everyone here
both at this meeting and duress previous
during previous meetings
but during the previous summit we have
discussed the ways to cleanse italy
from terrorists so that
so that civilians would not be
damaged would not be killed or harmed
what mechanisms should we choose to
achieve that
and this mechanism hasn't been uh used
so far
we have discussed
ceasefire today we have discussed all of
this but this is a temporary measure
terrorists needs to need to be
eliminated they need to be driven away
from
the region sovereignty of syria
needs to be restored in the region
as for the eastern bank of euphrates
currently american troops are present
there and we are concerned
that they have a long term
plans uh for this part of syria
we don't know whether they're actually
going to withdraw from
this part of syria so
there are some forces there are some
plans
that intend that include using
aggression
using hostile measures to resolve the
situation
but this area needs to be cleansed of
terrorists and returned to the syrian
government
too we believe
that the syrian people have
their inalienable rights and
they need to be preserved and they need
to have the right to
have their future their role in solving
the crisis we all
believe that territorial integrity must
be one of the principles observed
while resolving the crisis in syria
this goes for the idlib region
and for the territories around the
efrares river including the
eastern bank but but also fighting
terrorism
must also remain our priority wherever
those terrorists
are entrenched secondly we do not
support anything related
to separatism we believe that
a dialogue inside syria must
uh help restore must lead to a
restoration of the syrian
state and society
at the moment the syrian conflict
needs to be viewed through a number of
lenses
we have a joint border with syria
that spans over 900 kilometers
in this southern part of our country or
in the northern part of syria
there are efforts to
create a terrorist corridor
a corridor that needs to be destroyed
which is our
priority task it's a threat to us
the other issue is aleppo the situation
there
is as you well know
it's difficult there were a lot of
migrants and refugees there
the same could happen in idlib but
thanks
to joint efforts together with russia we
were able
to prevent these migrant
movements and over 300
000 people were able to remain
in their homes
still need to be very strong in dealing
with terrorist organizations
now we are dealing with the eastern bank
of euphrates
the summit today
led us to take a number of agreed a
number of steps
like we said the constitutional
committee needs to be created and the
number of other states needs to be taken
our turkish journalists will continue
please pass on the microphone
mr president uh the united states uh has
decided
to pull out from syria but
at the same time they have requested
their nato allies to set up
they have appealed to them to set up
monitoring
areas in syria uh i have a question to
president putin and president rouhani
you said that you understand our
concerns
such concerns uh turkey's concerns what
steps can be taken
in this regard as a member of nato
i'd like to note that
in this regard the u.s have expressed
their
decision and this decision has to do
with
president trump but at the same time we
can see that
his colleagues so to speak
did not always share his opinion
if this is a decisive action on part of
the
of on the part of uh mr trump we would
seize
a different situation but now they're
talking about
april or march when this is going to
take place
so we don't know whether this withdrawal
is actually going to take place
now as for these steps
the three astana process countries
are monitoring the situation closely
we would like to secure
territorial integrity of syria and
manbij
needs to be
freed from terrorists liberated from
terrorists
and but we should not uh
give any uh
land to terrorists in idlib we need to
remain
ensuring security for turkey
uh on its uh southern borders is
something that we
view with understanding um based on the
fact that there is uh
a um treaty an agreement
signed between turkey and syria which
also provides for a
common fight against terrorists and this
can
serve as groundworks
our security services and our military
uh
closely cooperate in this area and we'll
continue to do so and we believe that we
move on with such coordination in the
future
then success would be all but secured
but
uh ultimately we be we agree with the
turkish president
that the territorial integrity of syria
will be secured and insured
as the terrorist threat subsides in this
country
as for a withdrawal of american
troops from syria we know that the u.s
president
mr trump
has been working quite actively on
implementing
his promises he gave
before being elected this is a rare
occasion in american political life
in reality one of mr trump's promises
was to pull out u.s troops from syria
it's a different matter though that the
domestic political situation
in the u.s is such that president trump
is not always able
to fulfill his obligations
and promises uh uh whether that will
happen this time
we will see but so far we can say that
there are
there aren't any significant changes on
the ground in syria
but if changes occur if it happens
the only solution for
providing security for syria would be to
pass on
those territories under the control of
syrian of the syrian military
answering your first question
about the us we are not optimistic about
that
we're not optimistic about what the us
is saying
if the americans do
pull out their troops completely out of
syria that would be
very very happy news to the people of
syria
if they do the same and withdraw from
afghanistan from iraq from other regions
that would
always be good news but the thing is
over the past 20 years the u.s have
been consistently destructive in our
region
both in iraq and syria now in yemen
the role of the us has never been
positive
we believe that the u.s need to change
their ways
and understand that the way they've been
interacting with the region
is wrong they've chosen the wrong path
to work with us the actions of the
americans
uh will not uh bring anything good
neither to
themselves nor to the people of the
region
you you've seen what's been happening at
the meeting in warsaw
they haven't achieved anything the u.s
are clueless they don't know how to
proceed
both this administration and the pre and
the previous administration
uh are clueless about how to maintain
and secure the interests
of the region and so we believe that
the u.s
their policy towards the region as for
turkey we we know that we believe that
turkey's concern
is is correct
there have been a number of terrorist
acts that took place in iran
we have seen that some of these many of
these terrorists were
prepared by foreigners including the
zionists
the yes the terrorist act that took
place
yesterday the person
who committed it
she killed a number of our border
patrol people we understand that this is
a very
dangerous region and we need to fight
against terrorism
but i don't think that turkey is very
concerned with
the government of syria the future of
syria with the kurds
i think that turkey is mostly concerned
with the terrorist groups whatever
they're called
these terrorist groups need to be
destroyed
but our priority of course is the
territorial integrity of syria
and finally a question from a russian
journalist
hello my name is pablo de riben i'm from
a russia network i have a question for
all three presidents uh
you've talked about uh the issue of
syrian refugees and uh how acute it is
what else could be done to ensure their
ability to to go back home and who else
could do something
about it and why aren't they doing it
and a question to mr putin
on january 23rd during your meeting with
president erdogan
in moscow you cited
a letter from western powers to
a um an envoy of the u.n security
general
where they were essentially slowing down
the process of
uh summoning a constitutional assembly
in syria
has this situation changed let me
start by answering the uh the letter
part of your question
we have been actively working with our
partners both
from iran and from turkey our experts
from the military from the defense
ministries
and foreign ministries have been
actively uh consulting both
with the syrian government and with the
opposition
and i'd like to say that on the whole
we have been successful it's uh too
early
to state for certain but
i'd like to say that we don't understand
the position of some of our
partners with regard to the formation of
the constitutional committee because
we believe that we have
[Music]
done everything we've agreed to do and
so
what my opinion is
it's not just being slowed down it's
it's a sabotage
of the process
but despite all the differences of the
difficulties
we have continued this very intensive
work
and in the upcoming future we will
finally
achieve uh the actual
probable results and the sooner it is
done the better as for the humanitarian
component
certainly everyone
is interested in having the refugees
return to their homes
then everything needs to be done so that
the conditions of their life are decent
that they can lead good lives
and
limiting humanitarian aid in any way to
the syrian people
it's very strange and it's really
odd to hear that there are sanctions now
against
companies or individuals
who are providing this humanitarian aid
to the syrian people to the syrian
government
to restore infrastructure to restore
health care
everyone need to unite around
single as the single goal of helping
syria restore
its its society its people its
government
i would like to especially note
the process of preparing for
for a constitutional assembly in syria
undoubtedly the
this process is not uh going
too fast and in recent months uh
the efforts of for the special of the un
special envoy
to syria uh have been uh
contributing to this process uh it is
undoubtedly
it is under it it is beyond doubt that
uh soon
such a constitutional assembly will be
summoned and
the people of syria will be able to
decide on their future as one of the
warranters of the astana process
turkey
we and once again the astana format is
not an alternative to the geneva process
but on the other hand the geneva process
is not
functional while the astana process is
is functional and we can see that in
some some of the real
implications and will continue to work
within this format
our fourth meeting in sochi today
took place and our fifth summit
will take place in turkey
as for humanitarian aid
for syria unfortunately expected aid to
the people of syria
the promised aid to the people of syria
has not been
provided the eu had promised that um
3 billion euro would be provided and
then another
3 billion but only
uh 700 million
have been only one 1 billion 1700
million have been provided uh by the eu
and um the us only provided
some 750 million dollars for syria
and those figures
actually come through humanitarian
organizations
and they are directed to
refugees whereby turkey
uh has provided aid of
some 35 billion dollars for
refugees in turkish territory uh
some 310 000 uh
syrian refugees have have gone back to
their homes but
some 3 million syrian refugees
found refuge in turkey and only uh one
tenth of them have gone
back uh the arrests are remaining in
turkey right now
and the the money assigned
as uh aid for those uh refugees is not
going to turkish
to the turkish budget it is important uh
to we are discussing further steps uh
for uh
um syria but once we start those
that process where will those refugees
live in
tents that is why it's important to
ensure security in those territories
and build some infrastructure provide
some infrastructure
so that those refugees could go back and
uh
actually have somewhere to live and be
safe and secure
the west has only been promising there
are also some
countries of the persian of the gulf who
have been who have been
talking a lot blah blah blah but they
spend a lot of money on armaments uh
but when uh it comes to humanitarian aid
we don't really see that them
providing any and so we have our
questions uh
in this regard we're hoping that
restoration
in syria will start and the destruction
will
finally be over in that country thank
you
well we believe that the issue of
helping the refugees
return to their homes and the issue of
rebuilding syria
needs to be conditional to a number of
other issues such as the constitutional
committee and its launch which is a very
important process
everyone needs to help achieve this
but the fact that refugees find
themselves outside their own country
is a bad thing and
so for the people to return to their
country we need to look at the reason
of their leaving what was the reason was
someone killed was this an attack what
was that
as long as terrorists remain in syria as
long as
we haven't eliminated all of them
these people the refugees will not be
ready to return they will not uh be
confident that they will be secure
in syria we need to step
up our fight against terrorism in syria
and in all of other
places where security needs to be
maintained we need to help the refugees
to return to secure places
together with iran since the past year
we have been
providing humanitarian aid to syria we
believe that this is our responsibility
as a as a neighboring as a brotherly
country
we have been providing humanitarian aid
to the nation of syria
over this time we are just decisive
in helping syria
rebuild this would also require a lot of
investment and
i hope that the efforts of our three
countries over the future summits
will uh help that but this of course are
very
important uh issues thank you
you